[Music]
let's go to jessica in missouri what's
up jessica
hi um so my question is how do i deal
with basically being a single parent
when my husband works at night and on
top of that we just had a fire like
three weeks ago
i have a 15 month old and a five month
old
and i also work so how do i deal with
life basically your whole life is on
fire
yeah
wow okay so
hi jessica it's good to meet you hope
you're doing i hope you're doing well
um what's your favorite
band um
i don't have one i listen to a lot of
music
so i don't have a favorite so you're a
serial killer that's good all right so
um 10 and 10
months in five months wait what fifteen
months and five months and five months
they're 10 months and 25 days apart
are they adopted are they biological
biological we had one in february last
year and one in december of last year
dude i'm high-fiving you all the way
from nashville
wow okay
so yeah y'all are
there's y'all are crazy yeah no that's
not that bad it's not crazy it's i think
it's awesome but
y'all are in it but then there's like
y'all are in it in it okay so tell me
what happened to your house total loss
what happened ah
so we had a mobile home um that we owned
and we were like six months away from
being fully out of debt and then saving
to buy a house and my five-month-old had
thrush and my husband was working at
night so i was
you know dealing with both children and
had to boil the bottles and all that i
fell asleep while boiling the bottles
and our kitchen basically went up and
switched oh no
so is it a total loss
um a lot of smoke damage not full total
loss but it's not worth replacing so now
we're fighting with insurance just to
get the money we're supposed to get so
that we can then buy a house yeah we've
been with his parents the past months so
it's it's a lot
have you already had the uh
fire inspector come out and write you a
letter that this is what happened
yep okay we have a fire report all that
okay it's just insurance came back real
real low like they always do and so now
we got a back and forth
all right so tell me about husband
husband is fantastic he's an amazing dad
he's just an amazing human being he's
like my best friend um and we've been
through it since we got married and this
is just another thing but
it's just constant um and he hauls fuel
so he works friday saturday sunday
monday nights
and then he's also working on trying to
get out of a truck so he's also doing
electrical work to get his hours tuesday
wednesday and thursday gotcha um and he
has to stay up all night thursday so
that he can sleep friday so that he can
work all night friday night so he's
really only around
tuesday wednesday
maybe half a tuesday yeah
and by the way you know what you should
probably do right now is just live with
your in-laws
that sounds like a good
man yeah okay
so here's the bad news
the bad news is
i want you to
like take as deep a breath as you
possibly can and just hold it will you
do that
hold it
three four then let it go
i don't want you to drop your shoulders
pull them down like as low as they'll go
okay
you have to own the grief of the season
you're in
like your house is gone
and you're gonna have some guilt
please don't roll it into shame you're
gonna have some guilt because you put
the bottles on the stove right you fell
asleep
and
guilt is i can't believe i fell asleep
and the house burned down
shame is i'm a terrible mother and i'm a
terrible wife and i'm a terrible family
partner because i burned the house down
you see the difference
yeah one is yes i feel guilty i did this
like all this mess i'm we're living here
because i did this
and that happens if you try to run from
that it will chase you down so you got
to own that and
i don't want that you to start looking
at that as an identity or a character
issue okay
here's the good news
everything you're describing to me is
seasonal
like i'm just looking at six months and
12 months down the road and how
different things are going to be you're
going to have your own home your
husband's going to be out of a truck
working a regular job
your kids are you're not going to be
just constantly rotating between feeding
and changing diapers 24 7 365 over and
over and over again
your life is going to look incredibly
different and so what we're talking
about here is how do we maintain during
the cold hard winter
does that sound fair
yeah
because it feels like your whole world
is on top of you doesn't it
yeah essentially got married almost four
years ago because he did construction
for our entire dating relationship and
like two months after we got married he
got in the truck and was gone for two or
three months at a time for two years and
then when we got pregnant he found a job
that was
gone during the week and then home on
the weekend and then when we had our
first daughter then he was nighttime
so it was a lot of a lot a lot of things
have happened since we got married
um this is gonna sound like a crazy
question because you're surrounded by
people who love you but are you lonely
at times yeah
sounds like you'd be lonely a lot
when my girls are awake they're
fantastic and they help yeah just draft
from that they are not
that's not what i mean
i mean do you have two or three or four
women in your life
that come over and talk trash and
makes fun of you while you're making fun
of them and
like do you have those women in your
life that bring casseroles over and
all that stuff
i would if i asked but i don't ask
okay
so the key to the next six to 12 months
here what your life is in transition
is
you make a firm commitment
to your kids
to your husband
and bottom line to you
that you're worth having friends
and make a priority i'm gonna have
people in my life
on a daily basis if not a weekly basis
and i'm gonna start having friends even
if they just come over and prop their
feet up and they do their homework
because they're going back to school or
they just come over and they all they do
is hold your babies so you can just go
close your eyes for a minute all they do
is come over and y'all watch some dumb
netflix show or whatever
um or it would be really great for you
um if they came over and you all went
for a walk and you got a double stroller
and you all went and moved your body
okay got out of the house and went moved
um
but i want you to make having conhumen
connection a high high high priority
here's the second thing i want you to do
i said it a little bit you got to get
into some sort of movement you got to
move your body around okay will you
commit to that
yeah you don't got to go to crossfit
class like a lunatic but you do got to
get a double stroller and go for a walk
a couple of times a day
at least once a day let me say that a
couple times would be great or if you
can go for a run or your friend can come
over and you can run to the gym whatever
and i'm not saying to go get bulk up i'm
saying just move your body okay
here's the third thing and um i'm
shooting in the dark here on this okay
um
have you gone back to your house
yeah actually this week we're
taking everything out and sifting
through everything so but have you gone
back yet
yep i was there yesterday how was it
it sucks every time i go tell me about
it
um it just makes me feel sad yeah
um if you can i would love for you to
get one of those girlfriends of yours or
just go by yourself
just go and be sad
okay
there's something um there's a beacon
that was home and it's not anymore and
you spent a lot of two years alone in
that place
pacing
that's where your babies were born and
they came home to
and now it's gone
okay home
and i want you to go there and be real
real sad
is that cool
yeah it's best if you go with somebody
and this is gonna sound like if somebody
sees you doing what i'm about to tell
you to do they're gonna think they're
probably gonna call a psych ward on you
okay
um i would love for you to take a friend
over and just kind of walk through the
house and talk about where the memories
were
this is the room that we brought
five month home to
and this is the room
this is where five month old was
conceived and this is right and we're
gonna laugh and we're gonna tell stories
and this is where i got mad and threw
food against the wall and this is where
husband came home and always dropped his
underwear and it was gro i want you to
go through and feel this place
okay yeah because it's home and right
now home has become a
epicenter of trauma for you it's been
it's become a nuclear reactor
and i want to change that in your body
to where it is a warm place that's got
some laughter and some joy in it and
some great sadness because we're not
gonna live there anymore and by the way
you're about to move anyway
right yeah we're working really hard to
move and so this wasn't your forever
place it just got expedited so
we're gonna go there we're gonna walk
through it we're gonna talk about it and
we're gonna make peace with it and we're
gonna kick our shoes to dust off our
shoes when we leave and then when you go
back
it's gonna feel different you're gonna
feel lighter and then you go back and
you're gonna start moving and get all
your crap out of there get your stuff
out
and then you're gonna leave that to the
burned out box that it is
but your home's gonna go with you
so that makes sense
yeah sounds super woo-woo and cheesy if
you tell your husband to over-the-road
trucker like all right this is what this
guy told me to do he's gonna be like you
probably should never list that podcast
ever again
okay oh no he listens to y'all and he
probably listens to dave and you way too
much honestly at night because then he
festers and just thinks and things and
things
and
so it sounds like you got a husband
that's working
absolutely working his butt off because
he loves his family and he wants to make
things different is that true yeah
100 and you got two
unbelievable beautiful little kids that
are just too much right now but they're
still beautiful
yeah and you got a couple of friends who
would at a moment's notice
come in and come be a part of your life
um but you just won't call
pretty much and you've got two in-laws
that are just your in-laws they just
what do you say but they also open up
their home to you right you see what i'm
saying
yeah here's what i'm getting at
you have to feel this grief you got to
own this grief because it's real and
don't miss the beauty don't miss the
light coming through the darkness
because there's a lot of light around
you that's what i'm hearing
okay
yeah
we keep saying that we've fought many a
battle since we got married and this is
the war and god's working all the little
miracles around it and it's really hard
to see all the little miracles when
you're in this [ __ ] of what we're going
through that's right so so here's going
to do i want to change your language
okay
i want you to no longer you're not in
war anymore
what you've been doing for the last four
years is this the little farm y'all had
the soil was terrible
it's full of rocks and thorns and weeds
and nonsense and y'all been working for
four years
to change the soil
to clean that soil up to regenerate and
to heal that soil
and now y'all are planting
i much rather
a planting metaphor we're planting seeds
of trees that we might never even eat
the fruit off of them
but now we're planting because what that
tells me is at the end of a war there's
a bunch of dead bodies to pick up
at the end of a good planting season
is the
harvest and that is a radically
different psychological proposition for
your body
and so let's tell your husband we're not
fighting war anymore i declare war over
war is over
we're planting
we're getting ready we're turning this
sucker around we in and he has worked
you have worked you spent countless
lonely nights
countless single parenting nights
countless at nights getting advice from
your mother-in-law gosh
kellen said nice just wishing your
husband wasn't such a great hard worker
and he would just come home and sit on
the couch all stinky mess of him and
just hug you
all that work y'all put in
the harvest gonna be big it's gonna be
big
i'm super proud of you jessica
go make that call today okay